hey guys what's up I milano char Lana
welcome to my channel this is dragon age
inquisition and I've just finished
creating my character in the creation
menu here so i'm sure you guys the start
of the game let's do it oh who dat was a
pyramid head get back to your own game
this isn't tyler hill
okay hmm Oh God spiders man I hate them
so much there and every goddamn fantasy
game
ok so that's a lady
but what just happened here
hmm hmm I'm imprisoned him okay hurry up
your hand just sparked you might want to
get that checked out oh hello ladies two
synchro's why we shouldn't kill you now
the Conclave is destroyed everyone who
attended is dead oh except for you um ok
let's go remain silent ooh frown Aloha
Lane this I can't what do you mean you
come I don't know what that is or how it
got there you're lying huh she's a
little bit angry need em Cassandra
um hmm ok that's interesting
whatever you think I did I'm innocent do
you remember what happened they both
actually very well Hamid I remember
running things were chasing me and then
a woman a woman yeah he reached out to
me but then like I was hair is going
through his ear I will take him to them
like some time to sweet passing what did
happen
it
will be easier to show you hmm
I've not been led to be killed or
something that wouldn't be fun
what's that
maybe that's where I was what's the
green smokey stuff it's a massive rift
into the world of demons that grows
larger with each passing hour just
determine as eyebrows like for eyebrows
like just naturally angry all were
caused by the explosion at the Conclave
an explosion can do that this one did
unless we act the breach may grow until
it swallows the world so maybe the girl
a woman each time the breach expanded
that your mark spreads and it is killing
you it may be the key to stopping them
but there isn't much time so I don't
really have a choice about this Nunavut
has a choice well ripened disapprove
Cassandra your [ __ ] I'll her but do it
it won't they have decided your guilt
they needed the people of Haven mourn
our most holy divine Justinian head of
the Chantry the Conclave was hers it was
a chance for peace between majors and
Templars well she brought their leaders
together now they are dead
we lash out like a sky but we must think
beyond ourselves as she did until the
breach is sealed okay
she looks awesome I really like what
she's wearing I can promise no more come
it is not fun where are you taking me
know those little your mark must be
testing bottle things on our shoulders
look a bit shoddy um okay this is pretty
basic just running around to look at
things open the gate we are seen Ellie
it's pretty it's good into the valley we
go
at fine the journal okay cool let's do
it let's go k dog c-dawg she's even
coming you coming oh she waits for me
that's nice that's what she said that in
tysons Oh hectic the policies are coming
fast enough hmm
the larger the breach grows the more
risks appear the more demons we face how
did I survive the blast they said you
stepped out of a rift then we fell
unconscious they say a woman was in the
rift behind me Oh God okay whoa whoa
it's actually kind of does remind me to
start upon kingdoms of amalur a little
bit and I really enjoyed actually a
little time
they behind me okay mmm that is very
kudi looking smoke but all right yeah
stop
alright let's do it do the fighting okay
that's handed
anything you'd seem to well that's why
do oh nice ok the next oh man that's
cool all right sweet dude I would like
to go to evade whilst your weapon now
know if you're going to lead me through
a demon infested valley you'll have to
trust me give me one Mexican point will
trust you because my life is on the line
also the point you're right
you don't need a stop but you should
have one I cannot protect you hmm
I should remember you did not attempt to
run okay let's get nope lb don't really
need a health potion it seems to want me
to so hate people all right making a did
what moves we're um yeah it would nice
to forward can't be nice to be able to
evade y'all now or roll something you're
in combat and I'm not sure if I can
doesn't seem like it but this was
turn-based though dragon age mmhmm yeah
worktop yes new to all the things we may
gain the advantage
okay not home all right nice nice
effects i really like the way that it
looks when that happens that's very good
it's kill all y'all and then Lou Toyota
bodies because we respect the dead yeah
sure heck yeah shadow essence all about
that it's like my favorite thing how did
you know
I'll get it oh it's very I really don't
like that I can't move all I'm attacking
but um shaman's there's a reason for
that it would be nice to be able to kind
of just move around he's controlling
stuff though I suppose if you're
actually in this situation it would make
it very hard to I didn't use that we go
up and then hook still no up not that
one that no okay you know what I'm doing
wrong man I'm not using it okay yan I
suppose it would make it really hard to
aim magic tax you were moving around so
maybe it's other games that are
ridiculous and not this one so how do we
use that yes go up there and then o.o be
breast a I was pressing a button right
right all right let's keep going then
Sam what gets that so well it's a dead
body slightly covered in snow oh right
it's a really happy place I'm glad you
talked me out here Cassandra you
irresponsible person
just leading strangers out in it to the
monster field snow
really appreciate it ha
so it has like
I wonder if different things are we
different things i'm not sure that does
18 what's it like the other stream be
hard for me to tell that they don't know
it's just like it could your speed
that's like one of the attacks is
stronger than the other or somethin pay
attention next time i use one yeah Wiz
bezants oh my favorite second favorite
off to whatever the other one was thing
with shadow essence I love both of those
things that way no this way this way the
way of the stick is we're getting I feel
like this did we real cold hey yes 20
years it's a little compared to its
massive ass jaw mmm hello there it seems
like progress
all right let's check okay so why did 51
image to a thing you
X also do 51 okay so they did the exact
same oh hey there
what did you do I the credit is yours I
closed that thing how whatever magic
opened the bridge in this guy also
placed that mark upon your hand i
theorized the market has a lot where was
the rifts that have allowed us in our
wake something something else dear see
meaning it could also close the breach
itself possibly it seems you hold the
key to our salvation good to know here I
thought we'd be as deep and demons
forever nice cleavage bruh actually I
like how he does in the women don't know
just this one guy occasionally just so I
great like I see you're always gonna
have you know one half naked character
and this time it just happens to be a
guy so that's cool um well varric
tethras rogue storyteller and
occasionally unwelcome tag along ask us
bro that's cross-ice crossbow you up
there isn't she Bianca and I you named
your crossbow Bianca of course and
she'll be great company in the valley
absolutely not your help is appreciated
Varrick but have you been in the valley
lately seeker you're so yes Sandra
control anymore you need
you know who you're arguing with my name
is soulless if there are to be
introductions I am pleased to see you
still live he means I kept that mark
from killing you while you slept hmmmm
place you seem to know a great deal
about it all slightly improves huh so
less is an apostate technically all
mages and our apostates Cassandra my
travels have allowed me to learn much of
the fade far beyond the experience of
any circle mage I came to offer whatever
help I can give with the breach if it is
not closed we are all doomed regardless
of origin well I guess that answers that
and I'm gonna cut this off you guys this
has been the first 16 minutes it was
meant to be 15 but this is the first 16
minutes nearly 17 minutes of dragon age
inquisition I'm Alana thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you all next time